ああああああ
今日も暑いこんにちははじめ社長です多分これ知ってる人たぶんねこれ多分知って
るってが知ってて欲しい皆様市議フィックスっていうお菓子ってますでしょうか
一応ここであるんですけども知らない人もいるのかもしれないですね昔は猫民に持って
たんですけども最近なかなか売ってなくて
新感覚進行
ハードグミ済みなんですけども打たれたことはで人ならわかると思うんですけども
すごいんですよ売上てすごい
この言葉とになんで食ってたかわかんないくらいなくでて8食べてみますねあのボタン
ねちょっとからわかると思うんですけど主義 kicks っていう単語を言った瞬間
大樹がすごい出るくらいのそれぐらいめちゃくちゃ酸っぱいですちょっとひと粒食べて
みます
[拍手]
だくんあっはぁ
大2
ああ
今ジェッタはないと思うんですけどめちゃくちゃ酸っぱいんですよもう痛いぐらいの
酸っぱさのお菓子があるんですけども
今回はとある継承してみようと思いますこれは食べたことある人ならわかると思うん
ですけど
何度も言ってごめんねほんとにいっぱいですよまじで例えば誰か寝てるとするじゃない
ですか誰かが開けていてその寝ている時に3つの中根氏グイッと入れたら必ずを受ける
んじゃないかと言って
それが僕の中にありまして立っていたいの人には様々な感覚があります
味覚嗅覚視覚聴覚
[音楽]
9画いろんな感覚がある中でやはりですね性格というものは嫌
2確っていうのはいえなんですけども外的な2確とかじゃなくてもっと変化球普段の
生活だとまずありえないような角度からの攻撃による通貨クイッとなると人は目覚め
ちゃうんじゃないかと思いましてその中の神ピックぞ使いますベッテル鶏肉中中にたく
なるなんて操作ないと思うし今回検証したいことは
出てる人にし切っこそ無理に食べさせると必ず起きるのかっていう間倉地区していき
たいとおもいます
はいはいだけでまずは私が実験対象になります僕が寝静まった時に後輩にし切符素朴独
紙の中で放り込ませてもらいますでは4日
[拍手]
[音楽]
スポッ
ん
[音楽]
me
バーガー
います
どうぞう
ん
を
このあ
[音楽]
を
おはああ
はぁんっ
待ってああ待って待って
1個目は母
美味しかったんだよね美味しかったまあまあと思って食った
いやまうまっビターンおいたいな
茅部だめだ
1本切って全部はまずで起きる絶対口台も
して
違うん
[音楽]
goo
me
[音楽]
ん
スレチって直で逃げちゃった
イケダメっ
[音楽]
えっあれんあう集
うん
んこれ hane
me
dea
re だった
意外とイケるクチ
信長は gackt なく分な趣味
メロディで cx くーっと絶対起きれ雪っていうのがあったんだけど
うんを救っ俺聞いたからベトナムンってたから私懸命わかんないですよ多分結構だ
避けるずみんな起きると思うので是非おきれないかといったら試してみてはいかが
でしょうか
by y